hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts multiplex precision
genome editing with trackable genome
integrated barcodes and East presented
by dr. Kevin Roy postdoctoral scholar
Department of Genetics Stanford
University
I am Kaylee Baca blaggards and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labyrinth
labyrinth is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen type your
questions into the drop down box and
click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the help desk button
located in the promotional board at the
bottom center of your screen or use the
ask a question box to let us know that
you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Kevin Roy I will now turn the
presentation over to him great Thank You
Kaylee it's a pleasure to be able to
have the opportunity to present my work
today and I wanted to thank the lab
roots organizers for the invitation and
for putting on this really useful online
conference my name is Kevin Roy and I'm
a National Research Council postdoctoral
associate with the genome scale
measurements group at the National
Institute of Standards and Technology
also known as NIST as well as jointly
with the Stanford genome technology
Center at the Stanford University School
of Medicine and today it's my pleasure
to present our work on adapting CRISPR
casts 19 editing to a large-scale
precision editing platform with an added
a feature of incorporating trackable
genomic barcodes as part of the editing
process and so crispers has come on over
the last five years as a really useful
scalable platform because it's simple in
nature it's a two component system that
includes a protein nucleus the common
most common one known as caste nine and
the real powerful feature is that the
guide RNA to which it binds can be
programmed to target nearly any genomic
sequence and the applications are very
broad for being able to to target DNA
cleavage in virtually any cell and these
fan from biofuels and biotechnology to
medicine and potentially a precision
editing for therapies as well as in
pharmaceuticals and drug drug
development but the main application I'd
like to focus on today is the enormous
utility for this technology and basic
scientific research in understanding how
cells work and in modifying DNA sequence
at a large scale to test different
hypotheses about the function of the
cell and so it's good to take a step
back when using the system to understand
how it evolved and what it is what it
really does at its core level and so
that the CRISPR system was discovered
initially as a group of genes that
function in a related pathway as part of
a viral DNA immunity response so upon
infection of a bacterial cell by virus
the there is a complex of proteins
composed of cast one and cast two that
are known as the integrase complex that
interrogate the viral DNA and
incorporate segments of this viral DNA
into the bacterial genome in this locus
known as the CRISPR locus which was
originally interesting because of its
repetitive nature interspace by these
spacer sequences
corresponding to viral DNA and so this
is just the beginning of the process
this is the immunization phase once
these viral DNA segments are
incorporated into this repeat segment
the bacterial genome is transcribed into
RNA and this RNA is then processed by
the bacterial host cell enzymes into
individual repeat spacer fragments which
are then bound by protein cast 9 and so
it's important in the context of an
immune system that the main function of
this system the protein RNA nucleus is
to cut viral DNA with high efficiency
and in many cases it's not that critical
whether or not there's a mutation in the
viral genome at the target site all that
matters is that the bacterial immune
system doesn't cut its own genome it
only cuts the viral DNA so that's an
important consideration later on when
we're thinking of designing donor DNA s
that will introduce small changes to the
sequence and so the important aspect
about this system is that the the
targeting sequence is short and
reprogrammable so the cast 9-pound guide
RNA is shown in red and blue here from 5
prime to 3 prime and the red sequence
solely functions to bind tightly to the
cast line protein the sequence in blue
can actually be reprogrammed to target
any desired sequence the only
restriction is that it be adjacent to
what's known as the proto spacer
adjacent motif pam in the case of caste
9 and gg upon reprogramming these guide
ironies cast iron guide RNA complex will
scan the genome for the target site that
has a pam and it will then introduce two
cuts typically a blunt end cut three
base pairs upstream from the pam and so
again it's important to note that
the cast 9 guide are in a complex all
all it does is cut the genome in at at a
site and create a double strand break
what's really important in the context
of gene editing is what happens after
and so there are three main possible
outcomes of the double strand break
the first one is non-homologous end
joining where a complex of proteins will
recognize the broken ends and simply put
the pieces back together occasionally an
error is made in this process and that
air will actually render the target DNA
resistant to further cutting the the air
is typically a an insertion or a
deletion of a few nucleotides but the
main point here is that it's somewhat
non-deterministic the outcome and so
this process is mainly used to disrupt
sequences and particular open reading
frames a second outcome is cell death
because the the cleavage process itself
is slightly toxic and depending on the
cell state at the time of cleavage the
cells will undergo apoptosis the third
outcome which is preferable in many
systems is homology directed repair and
this utilizes the cell's endogenous
system to repair a sequence using in
many cases the homologous chromosome or
in the case of gene editing an exogenous
segment of DNA which we call the donor
DNA and so in this pathway the sequence
is flanking the break must be perfectly
homologous to the donor DNA for a given
stretch for the editing to occur
efficiently and the outcome of this
process is the precise change which is
defined in the donor DNA which can be
very useful for changing amino acids to
particular substitution sequences or
changing binding sites to a particular
specific site and so what's important to
look to think about is actually under
the hood of this process of cutting and
repair are many cycles
perfect repair and so it's not it's not
clear exactly how many cycles occur
before an endpoint is reached which an
endpoint is either that nhej a cell
death or HDR editing but this is an
ongoing process so that the cell does
not always repair the cut with a change
in many cases it will repair it
perfectly and you'll get cut again and
so if we take a step back and look at
what are the the important developments
in Biosciences which have enabled a
deeper understanding of this how the
whole cell functions we've had an
enormous revolution in measure high
throughput measurement technology
starting with measuring DNA RNA the
proteome metabolites and lipids at a
large scale or we can measure many
components at once and we've also had
technologies that enable perturbing many
parts of the cell at the same time and
these include media genesis randomly
through chemical methods or radiation
methods genetic methods to induce knock
out collections by synthetic genetic
arrays to combine knockouts at a large
scale and in more scalable methods for
performing screens in a pool format
include the RNA interference and more
recently CRISPR interference as well as
CRISPR cutting utilizing the nhej a
pathway but the limitation of all these
perturbation approaches is that they are
primarily probing the function of genes
by either changing the expression levels
up or down or by completely knocking out
function and while that's useful we
still lack robust tools for introducing
precise sequence changes utilizing donor
DNA as opposed to utilizing nhej a and
you can think of it as the difference
between a search and replace function in
your word processor that simply allows
you to delete specific words and
randomly get some sort of outcome from
that
or being able to add in a replace text
that precisely allows you to change one
word to another all throughout a
document and that's what we're looking
for with a system that utilizes donor
DNA at a large scale
so in order to implement this system
we've utilized all of the nucleotide
array synthesis and the benefit of this
format of DNA synthesis is that it
allows us to synthesize thousands to
hundreds of thousands of individual
sequences all together on a single slide
and these sequences are designed on the
computer and essentially printed on two
glass slides and after the sequences are
are printed they are actually washed off
and pooled all together into the same
tube and the advantages allows one to
process many samples in a multiplexed
fashion without having to have thousands
of individual tubes and so what what our
method incorporates into this process is
the inclusion of the guide sequence and
the donor sequence on the same DNA
molecule these sequences are separated
shown in red here by a restriction
restriction site and flanked by common
priming sites the the amplification of
these oolagah nucleotides is accompanied
by the inclusion of a barcode on the
reverse primer this barcode is important
because it allows us to tag each guide
donor that is cloned with a unique 30
mer in this case sequence and what we
can then do is is sequence this
intermediate clone plasmid library
utilizing primers that flank the barcode
and the guide and obtain high high
quality sequences using next-generation
sequencing where we associate each guide
and donor with a specific barcode and
this is important because the
oligonucleotide synthesis process
occasionally introduces errors into the
guide and the donor
so for any given guy donor sequence a
large fraction of them and upwards of 40
to 50 percent will contain errors and we
need to be able to distinguish those
errors from the sequence perfect
molecules and the barcode allows us to
do that and it also allows us to track
each strain by sequencing just the small
barcode as opposed to the entire guide
donor sequence so this is just an
intermediate step of cloning the next
step involves inserting these the guide
RNA scaffold which is necessary to bind
cast 9 shown in red as well as yeast and
bacterial markers so this platform we've
initially optimized it using the yeast
system as a model eukaryote and so we
take the this is called the step 2
plasmid library and we transform this
into the G cells which Harbor cast 9
either inducible or a pre expressed one
of Castine so after transforming this
guy donor library we we induce cast 9
and the guide and with this what this
does is it produces an edit at the
target site and on this guy donor plasm
we also have a second guide RNA which
actually targets this the own the the
same plasmid from which its expressed
the guy donor plasmid and this guide RNA
also targets a specific engineered site
in the genome which we call the barcode
locus and what this effectively does is
it integrates the entire guide donor
cassette stabili into the genome and at
the same time it linearizes the guide
donor plasmid to produce a superior
homologous recombination template to
produce the editing so at the end of
this process we have the integrated
guide donor barcode as shown on the left
and on the right we have the specific
variant allele which can be introduced
throughout the genome and mediated by
the donor DNA on the plasmid
and so we call this system majestic
which stands for multiplexed accurate
genome editing was short trackable
integrated cellular barcodes and this I
wanted to emphasize the the multiplex
nature of the system and that we're not
just producing one edit at a time we're
producing thousands of edits at a time
and but we start with a population of
cells that's otherwise isogenic or the
same and we we deposit a desired edits
throughout the genome and each edit is
accompanied with its own specific
barcode and the barcode the first
purpose of the barcode again is to
distinguish the perfect guy donors from
those that contain errors and the second
purpose of the barcode is to enable us
to grow this population of cells in many
different conditions under which these
different genetic variants impart
differential Fitness impacts to those
cells and by doing this pooled growth in
these different conditions and we can
compare to the reference condition we
can gain an understanding and get an
understanding of how these specific
genetic variants impact fitness and the
way we do that is by simply counting the
barcodes using next-generation
sequencing and so as a proof of
principle for this approach we we edited
a gene called ad 2 which is a gene
required for adenine biosynthesis and
strean is often used in in yeast editing
because it provides a simple readout of
the editing result which is a red color
of the cell due to the accumulation of a
pigment intermediate in the adenine
biosynthesis pathway and so first what
we did was we we cloned a representative
plasmid which contains an ad to guide
and donor and it transformed this
plasmid into a cell which contains an
inducible form of caste line so we can
induce caste lines simply by a metabolic
shift from glucose to galactose and over
the course of
teen generations we can take time points
of the edited population and sequence
the target edit to see what's actually
happening are we actually producing the
desired edit and what you can see here
is initially we start with 100%
wild-type sequence and over five
generations that that sequence drops
towards zero and we get an increase in
the sequence of and the sequences the
represent perfect donor repair but in
this system we also see considerable
nhej a in Dells at the target site and
these reach roughly 20 to 25 percent by
the end of the editing process at the
same time we can introduce these
barcodes by Co expressing these to guide
RNA skyed X as we call it and the add to
guide and the the integrated barcode we
can ask that using PCR across the
barcode locus and it shows us a
increased size migration here and the
the recipients ID at the beginning just
contains this counter selectable fcy one
marker which contains a lower size so we
can see over the course of five to seven
generations we're reaching near complete
integration of this barcode and by nine
to eleven is essentially complete and
we've done this also with with a complex
pool in addition to the single add to I
don't a plasmid and these show similar
barcode integration kinetics what we can
also do is look at how efficient the
destruction of the guide donor plasmid
is in this process so as its integrated
into the genome this guy donor plasmid
is also cut in that cutting linearizes
the plasmid and renders it unable to be
replicated further so it essentially is
self destructed in this process and we
can see that the loss of the guy donor
Klaus made essentially levels off around
nine generations it's nearly completely
lost and so we can also perform these
experiments in cells that cannot perform
in hej using
a mutation in any j1 gene and this
allows us to completely get rid of the
undesirable editing that's due to the
random insertions deletions from any GJ
and here we can obtain a hundred percent
precision editing using the donor DNA
and so another way of looking at the
barcode integration is to see how how
much of how much of the clones have
removed the FC why one marker at the
barcode locus and initially we see very
little survival on the 5 FC which
counter selects against FC by one in
over five to ten generations we see the
survival approach 100% with very little
change so this indicates that indeed we
have integrated these markers into the
genome and the advantage is that the the
barcode being stabili integrated is no
longer needed to be maintained on a
plasmid and so we can grow the cells in
any any condition without having to keep
selection for the plasmid and so in the
course of this work we found that while
editing and galactose is able to produce
high levels of precision editing up to
eighty percent in the presence of NH TJ
which can be pushed to 100 percent in
the absence of any hej when the editing
is done in glucose with constitutive
caste line and guide with either the
guide donor expressed first the caste
line expressed first we were really
surprised to find that any GJ was not
observed whether or not any j1 is
present and so this indicates that the
metabolic state of the cell or the
precise conditions under which caste
line and the guide are induced and have
a profound impact on the editing process
itself and another thing to keep in mind
in this process is that editing is very
toxic and roughly 10 percent or less of
cells actually survive the process so
this is a representative experiment
where we
is forming an attitude guide donor
plasmid on the left or an equivalent
amount of guide donor plasmid that
contains a mutated guide RNA and you can
see the huge difference in colony
numbers after the transformation process
indicating that on the left many of the
cells that actually receive this plasmid
and cut the genome don't survive the
editing process and so in a multiplex
setting what what you can now simulate
is what will happen when we have guy
donor sequences that contain mutations
or guys that guides that don't function
well and so if we spike in these
plasmids in a simulation of a library at
1% or 10% we see that by 10% the number
of white colonies here which represent
the mutated guide donor are already
beginning to dominate the the colonies
that contain the guide donor the
functional guide donor and so this is a
problem for screens because we have most
of the cellular population not producing
an edit and it will just it will
increase the the size of the screen as
well as lower the efficiency of finding
the genetic variants of interest so in
order to address this issue we developed
a system to improve the survival of the
editing process by actively recruiting
the donor DNA to the side of the breaks
and we use the system that yeast
naturally use to repair double strand
breaks at the mating type locus and we
adapted it for the guide donor editing
and the system involves the protein
called FK h1 and in order to adapt it to
guide donor editing we fused Alexei
Alexei DNA binding domain to the C
terminus of this protein and we then can
introduce Alexei stop finding binding
sites adjacent to the donor sequence on
the plasmid and what this allows us to
do is target this FK h1 protein to the
plasmid then we can induce editing
create the double strand break and what
happens when the double strand breaks
are created
our that signaling cascade is induced
where threonine residues on various
proteins are phosphorylated and the
exact identity of these protease
proteins that are phosphorylated and
bound by fkh one is still under
investigation but it includes among
others mph one a helicase involved in
DNA repair and FTO one and so what what
the end result of this process of
binding to the phospho three innings and
the lacks a sides is to recruit this
donor DNA directly to the cut site and
it's important to keep in mind that the
genome is a very vast place for DNA
there's millions of base pairs in the
east and in even cells billions of base
pairs and in the DNA repair process the
cell is the enormous challenge of
finding a stretch of 50 to 100 bases of
identical sequence amidst millions to
billions of a competitor sequence so
this process of donor recruitment
greatly simplifies the search for a
suitable template for repair and so we
as a proof of principle we implemented
the system on the add to editing in this
case utilizing 15% a spiking of a
non-functional plasmid so the
non-functional plasmid gives rise to
these white colonies or as the
functional add to guide donor gives rise
to the red colonies and you can see that
the plates the transformations that
black either Aleksei sites or the Lexx a
fork in protein or both produce mostly
white colonies but when we combine both
Aleksei sites and the Lexx a forked
fusion protein we now see a dramatic
shift in the fraction of edited cells
and so we can represent this by count
actually just counting the fraction of
red colonies versus white colonies and
we can see a greater than fivefold
increase in the efficiency of homologous
recombination in this process and what's
even more dramatic is it a the ratio of
red colonies of white colonies now
approaching the spikin ratio so we're
reaching nearly nearly sixty five to
seven
percent whereas the spike in ratio is
roughly is 85% of the ad to guide donor
plasmid and again remarkably the
presence or absence of any GJ does not
appear to have an impact in this process
when we are editing with a constitutive
cast line system in the presence of
glucose and so one of the concerns might
be that we we don't yet know if all the
red colonies are actually producing the
designed edits that we introduced into
the donor DNA so we can do now a
sequence that they add to targeted locus
and check to see what the sequence
matches and so here you can see is that
in the absence of the donor recruitment
system which I've fought the three left
columns we see mostly wild-type sequence
which corresponds to the white colonies
on the plate whereas we see only a small
fraction of edited sequence due to the
donor DNA now in the presence of the
donor recruitment system we see that the
donor editing sequences rise to 50
percent which is slightly less than the
65 to 70 percent we see here and that's
because the all the red colonies are
actually smaller due to the growth
defect that's introduced so they
contribute proportionately glass
sequence reads so we we zoom in on the
very minor fraction of reads that don't
correspond to wild-type and donor we do
see a very minimal level of nhej a in
the system so it's on the order of 0.5
percent or less and we can see that even
use it utilizing the donor recruitment
it does decrease the level of NH TJ and
we see a very small fraction of cells
that incorporate only partially the
sequence changed from this donor DNA
which we call an imperfect donor repair
so we wanted to then take this editing
system to a larger scale and what their
multiple applications where we
to edit many different sites across the
genome or across a gene and one case
would be to understand the function of
all amino acids for example in a protein
and for a while we had worked on it on a
protein involved in lipid signaling
called sec 14 and this was particularly
interesting to us because it is a
promising drug target for pathogenic
fungi and it's the target of a small
molecule that finds it very specifically
so we thought that by editing the sec 14
open reading frame exhaustively we could
identify mutations that are important
for the protein function as well as that
mediate resistant increased resistance
or sensitivity to the small molecule
drug that binds it and so the strategy
that we took was to design guide RNA and
donor DNA pairs or the the donor DNA
introduces an amino acid substitution
but also includes some synonymous
mutations adjacent to that substitution
which were designed to prevent the guide
RNA from cutting the donor DNA so if we
go back to this so the earlier slide
where we we showed that the CRISPR
immune system mainly is evolved to cut
donate to cut the viral DNA with a high
efficiency it's important to keep in
mind that when we have donor DNA is very
close has a close resemblance to the
actual target sequence it is possible
that mismatch or - or in this case 3 it
will still be cleaved by the guide RNA
so to prevent that from happening in
this design we actually can include
these synonymous changes shown in blue
which will prevent completely prevent
the cutting of the donor DNA so in order
to address the concern that these
synonymous changes have potentially have
some effect on their own we include a
control we have only the synonymous
changes on top and and below that we
include the synonymous changes with the
desired variant change and we can then
introduce every amino acid substitution
with either upstream synonymous changes
or downstream synonymous changes in two
different guide RNAs in each case and at
the end compare the results of these
different genetic variants to see if
they agree and so as sec 14 is an
essential gene we we wanted to make sure
that we were making all of the edits
that we designed without having to be
concerned about the effect of the edits
on the protein function and so the
approach we took was to utilize genetic
suppression of the sec 14 deletion and
these are these suppressors are in the
kes 1 or cgi one gene so what that means
is if we have a cell that lacks c ki 1
or guess one those cells will tolerate
loss of function mutations in Sector 14
so we can do the editing in the haploid
suppressor background where SEC 14 is
not essential then we can mate though
that library of edited cells to the
complementary suppressor in this case
the C ki one second 14 Delta and what
we'll get at the end of that process is
a diploid cell that contains CK CK 1 and
kes 1 which renders SEC 14 essential but
only has one copy of SEC 14 which is
derived from the library so this allows
us to look at the haploid population of
the set of the SEC 14 guide donors that
are edited first and then after meeting
to the diploid we can then examine the
distribution of of variants and make
conclusions about the fitness effects of
these variants so what we're showing
here are the sequencing of the edited
SEC 14 region and we are comparing the
sequence counts for the design variance
in the diploid relative to the haploid
and this allows us to see again the
fitness effects of each of these
variants so we can see immediately
notice at the top the premature
termination codons that we introduce are
are depleted in the diploid and that's
due to the the fact that this is an
essential gene so that was a really good
positive control but now we can see
specific amino acid substitutions that
have dramatic fitness effects on this
protein and so one of the positions that
jumps out for example is D 115 and we
can also see D 115 doesn't tolerate many
amino acid substitutions and we can also
see that for a region from P 122 f 123
lysine or arginine which are positively
charged amino acids are generally not
tolerated in that region and we can also
see that prolene which is an amino acid
introduces a kink into the peptide
backbone is generally just is largely
disfavored at and this region as well as
in other other positions throughout this
portion of the protein so what we could
then do with this library is add this
drug which binds to SEC 14 and then see
how all these different amino acid
substitutions impact the ability of the
drug to bind in the protein so when the
drug binds to the protein in devack and
in activates the function of SEC 14 and
the cells die so if mutations prevent
the drug from binding that will actually
result in enhanced resistance to the
drug relative to the wild-type or if the
mutations somehow enable or assist the
drug in binding to the protein or
compromised the function of the protein
in the presence of the drug that will
result in enhanced sensitivity to the
drug and we will see fewer reads for
those for those genetic variants so here
what we're showing in on the bottom in
blue boxes are those amino acid
substitutions that greatly enhance
resistance to the drug and so here
what's interesting is that we can see
immediately one position jump out why
111 where all amino acid substitutions
that are not hydrophobic so anything but
phenylalanine isoleucine leucine
methionine or tyrosine or tryptophan or
valine tend to increase resistance and
we can also see
of various other positions which show
numerous substitutions that enhance
resistance to the drug including a 104 p
108 and P 120 and so there are also
various positions which enhance
sensitivity to the drugs shown in red
and so this allowed us to to map these
meet these amino acid positions on to
the known structure of the protein and
as well as predict where the the
computationally predict where the drug
is probably finding the protein to
obtain a deep understanding of how these
amino acids interact with a drug in
immediate sex 14 function so y 111 for
example we can see in the lower left
here mediates a direct hydrophobic
contact with the aromatic ring of this
drug and so many of these amino acid
resistant amino acid mutation is a 104
and y 111 and Y 120 who Eric van der
Waals hydrophobic distances to bind to
this truck look how of any of the
positions were actually not predicted to
directly bind the drug and those are
very interesting because they imply that
there's some distance effects where
there's some confirmation don't change
it must occur in order for this drug to
buying in that these mutations block
potentially block those conformational
changes so as this was a screen done
with thousands of different genetic
variants we wanted to actually validate
that the results of the screen and that
this technology really is producing
accurate and precise results so we took
a few different amino acid substitutions
shown and shown with asterisks in the
lower left and we recreated those
individually independently verified each
edit and grew them in separate cultures
in the presence or absence of this drug
and what we found is that the results
very closely matched what we see in the
screen so with regards to both the
direction of resistance or sensitivity
as well as the map
we can see that l1 26 where we only see
two very resistant substitutions E&C
both replicated the validation
experiment and l1 26 I was dramatically
much more sensitive to the drug relative
to the wild-type so this gave us
confidence that the Majestic technology
really is a powerful tool to to look at
thousands of different edits at the same
time and give a really rich profile of
the function of protein sequence and so
we wanted to then take this to a broader
application and the one we picked was to
look at how genetic differences between
individuals actually contribute to their
phenotypes and yeast is actually a very
appropriate model for this because
different strains of yeast across the
world exhibit genetic differences much
like different people do in a population
and even more so the actual fraction of
genetic differences in the genome is
roughly similar on the order of 0.1
percent so one in a thousand base pairs
are different and and while it's mostly
the similar we see that even in human
populations we have many different
differences in disease susceptibility
and how how individuals are going to
respond to treatments and this is really
the basis for the push for precision
medicine I'm utilizing genomic sequence
and so what we can do is use yeast as a
model to understand how did genetic
differences actually control phenotypes
in the past so this this process was
done using either segregate panels where
genome sequences are shuffled and by
shuffling many different genome sequence
by shuffling the sequences of two
different parents at many different
locations throughout the genome just
using meiosis we can obtain statistical
narrowing down of the regions that are
correlated with a particular trait or in
the case of natural populations such as
when we look at
and genome sequences we can do
genome-wide Association or jiwa studies
where we obtain correlations between
particular variants in a phenotype
now these approaches are powerful but
they're very limited because even at the
the most narrowing of these regions of
statistical significance there's
typically hundreds to thousands of
genetic variants in those positions and
so actually identifying the causative
nucleotides that are involved in these
traits is is very time consuming and
very difficult so we sought to turn this
process on its head by introducing all
of the genetic variants individually
initially into the same genetic
background and using that process to
understand in a one-step experiment what
are the actual nucleotides or genetic
variants that are responsible for a
given trait and so we first looked at
two different strains that are commonly
used in evolutionary genetic studies one
is the lab strain called estimated see
another one Haram 11 which is a wines of
wild wine strain and these strains have
very different traits and phenotypes and
responds to different environmental
conditions and so if we look at what are
the variants that we can actually target
using the caste 9 guide RNA it's roughly
about 75 percent 70 to 75 percent of all
the genetic variants can be targeted I'm
using the ngg pam and many of those can
actually be targeted with two different
guide RNAs so we can utilize that for a
little bit of redundancy so we can
design these libraries clone them and
induce these edits at a large scale so
at the end we get a very complex plasmid
library that we we can interrogate we
can integrate those barcodes into the
genome when we produce the edits and
then we can sequence the barcodes
now that the edits are all over the
genome we use the barcodes to understand
how are the edits affecting cellular
function and in the beginning how
we introducing these edits as a function
of their toxicity so we can look at the
guides to understand how toxic the
editing processes itself so we can take
advantage of the synthesis errors that
are in the guide sequences and here we
call those dead if they're in Dells that
are within the first 15 base pairs of
the guide sequence or multiple snips so
we predict that these guides are not
going to function and what we can see is
that during the editing process these
bar codes are enriched as we might
expect because even in the even when
we're using the donor recruitment system
the editing is still quite toxic and so
we can then separate these guides into
whether their sequence perfect or
near-perfect or have a perfect donor as
well in addition to that we've also
characterized an important component of
the guide sequence called the t-score
which is a metric of how how dense the
the number of T residues are and we
found that that actually has a
significant negative impact on guide
efficiency so then if we look at the
actual sequence perfect guide sequences
relative to the dead guide sequences we
can now see how the location of the snip
which is the most common natural variant
that we're introducing relative to the
Pam impacts the editing toxicity in this
case so we can see that in what's called
the seed region for the guide within the
first 10 bases from the Pam there's
roughly an equal distribution of
abundance before and after editing but
in the fruit and the distal pan
positions we do see a drop out in the
guide barcodes and what this really
indicates is that we're getting an
additional toxicity above the editing
process for these donor DNA's and this
this is representative of the donor DNA
being cleaved by the guide RNA in
addition to the target site and so if
you recall that the CRISPR system
involved to cleave viral DNA
with a high on target efficiency um it
did not evolve to be highly specific for
very very similar sequences especially
when snips are are are far away from the
seed sequence and so this is an
important consideration when using donor
DNA to make edits is that uh when the
when the Edit is far away from the cut
side or the pan
the chances of cleaving the donor DNA
will increase and those are edits that
are going to be either impossible to
make or will require a different nucleus
perhaps a high fidelity cast 9 for
example that will be less mismatch
tolerant and so we can then look among
the sequence perfect guides at this
t-score metric which is a metric of the
density of T residues and the reason
that's important is because a stretch of
T's will actually terminate
transcription in eukaryotes which use
the pol 3 promoter and the Paul 3
promoter is the most commonly used guide
RNA promoter so this is an important
consideration when editing across the
genome because many regions which we
want to edit are T rich and so this
involves keeping that in consideration
when attempting to edit in genome wide
and so we can compare the guides as
sorted by their T score range versus the
corresponding predicted scores from the
azimuthal girl and azimuth is a guide
effectiveness predictive algorithm which
has proven to be very useful in many
systems beyond yeast and so we wanted to
compare how well just just incorporating
the T score alone compares to predicting
effectiveness by azimuth and you can see
it does very similarly for lower T score
ranges but with higher T scores the T
score alone appears to predict the
effectiveness of these guides as well or
even slightly better than azimuth and
that's largely due to as some you
being trained on guides that have higher
tea scores and so to prove that the tea
stretch actually impacts editing
efficiency by reducing guide RNA
abundance we actually sequence the
entire population of guide rnas and
normalized their abundance relative to
the guy DNA and we classified the
t-score based on the the stretch of tees
and whether or not they're interrupted
by one or two nucleotides so the
interruption by a single nucleotide was
given a penalty of 0.5 and two different
nucleotides of nineties were given a
penalty of 2.5 for example and what we
found was that as the t-score reaches
five or higher we see a dramatic drop in
the guide RNA abundance and so this
again is a indication that use it
utilizing this T scoring guide or any
design will improve editing efficiency
we then picked random clones from this
population to see what's actually
happening at the target site when we try
to edit genome by not just in an open
reading frame but across the entire
genome in some telomeric regions in
non-coding regions as well as open
reading frames so what we found is that
if we segment the the 15 clones we
analyzed here by whether or not they
have a effective guide by the T score
metric we we can see that five of the
guides had high T scores and do not
produce an edit as we expected now of
the guides that had lower T scores
meaning higher effectiveness we noticed
six out of ten
produced the designed edit and you can
see these are indicated in the name of
the guide sequence here and the donor
with the snip so these are snips that
position for anywhere from one to five
from the pan for this library and so
we've this work has recently been
accepted in Nature Biotechnology
and so it will soon be online too for
all the viewers to look at
but this was a important point for us
because we wanted to we wanted to
understand why we're producing the edits
when we are and why in some cases were
not so that's the the next stage of this
project going forward is to really
characterize efficiency at a broader
level so relative to other guy donor
systems that are in use I wanted to just
show a few comparisons as we wrap up and
so all of these other systems use the
guide donor or the donor as the barcode
and it's difficult to distinguish
synthesis from sequencing years when you
do that applies all of these other
system utilized plasmid based barcodes
so they're not genome integrated in this
requires constant selection and the
caste line breaks are repaired passively
by homologous recombination without
donor recruitment so the Majestic system
has several advantages we have the
barcoding step distinguishes synthesis
from sequencing errors we integrate
these pauses and barcodes into the
genome so they're stable and they they
don't need to maintain any selection so
we can grow the cells in any condition
and we have a process of active donor
recruitment which increases the
precision editing efficiency and we we
are excited to by the prospect that this
system could be utilized in other cell
lines on potentially even human cells to
improve editing where nhej a is very
prevalent and the other I think major
takeaway is that the exact conditions of
editing so not just cast 9 and the guide
but the exact metabolic state of the
cell and the induction kinetics of cast
9 in the guide can have a substantial
impact on the outcome of editing so this
is something we're on an ongoing area of
investigation to understand how can we
modulate the the cell conditions to
produce desirable editing outcomes and
so I'd like to acknowledge the team
behind this work which is not just at
Stanford but also
then witness the National Institute of
Standards and Technology as well as our
collaborators at the European molecular
biology laboratory and I'd like to thank
lab roots especially for hosting this
really useful conference and all of you
for your attention thank you thank you
dr. Roy for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for let's get started
our first question asks why must guide
RNA and donor DNA sequences remain
physically linked throughout the cloning
process so that's an important question
so the guide in many editing systems in
different cell lines the guide the donor
is supplied separately and the reason
why that wouldn't work in this case is
because the guides and the donors are
actually targeting different sequences
and because they're all in the same tube
if at any time during the cloning
process they become detached or
disassociated they will all mix together
with other guide and donor sequences and
it would result in miss pairing of a
guide with an inappropriate donor that
was supposed to be with a different guy
so this this restriction makes it very
important that from the step of
synthesis the guide and the donor are
always linked throughout this cloning
process through to the internal cloning
step here another question we have here
is what is the benefit of introducing a
short bar code for the guide donor
sequence at step one of cloning so again
the one of the major concerns with using
array based synthesis is that the error
rate can produce roughly 50 percent of
the sequences that come off the array
will contain a mutation some of those
some of those synthesis errors will be
in the guide sequence some in the donor
sequence and when you're actually
sequencing those regions with with
next-generation sequencing you also get
sequencing errors and so it's very
difficult to distinguish sequencing
errors from synthesis areas so the
barcodes essentially allow a unique
molecular identifier for each guide and
donor and it allows us to align many
different sequencing reads for a given
guide donor barcode and gain a consensus
sequence which then allows us to assign
synthesis errors or not to a given
barcode this next question says how long
does the entire process take from
cloning to phenotyping so that the
cloning process is a multi-step process
and from the point of amplifying the
library to cloning and transformation it
can take upwards of two weeks assuming
each step goes as desired so it's
important that after each step that the
library is adequately covered so you
need many more transform ins than
library members roughly 20 in the range
of 10 to 20 to 50 X is ideal to make
sure that the library is not skewed or
lost throughout this process okay we
have time for one more question and this
last one asks what are the major hurdles
to implementing Majestic and other
organisms and human cell lines so
probably the the biggest hurdle will be
the prevalence of n hej as shown here so
as as I showed with just by modifying
the conditions of of the yeast cell
growth we can actually favor homology
directed repair over N hej and we can
even favor it over cell death by
utilizing the donor recruitment method
other cell lines are very active in an
Ag J in particular human cell lines and
so it'll be very important to find
strategies that both reduce n hej either
genetically or transiently with small
molecules in these other cell lines in
order to in order to obtain an
efficiency or image or a majestic like
approach could work in human cells and
we do think that it is a promising
approach to use this a donor recruitment
because the process of recruiting
proteins to a double strand break is
conserved and that adapting donor
agreement in other cell systems is
really a matter of finding what are the
right partner proteins to bind the donor
DNA and so that's sort of it's an
ongoing work but I think it will be
possible if we can address both the NH
EJ inhibition as well as increasing the
efficiency of homology repair I would
like to once again thank dr. Kevin Roy
for his presentation I would also like
to thank lab roots for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing their August 2018 will
receive an email from labyrinth where
this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye